hey guys how's it going it's Justine and
today I am going to be showing you this
really cool iPhone case I don't have it
on my phone yet obviously it's still in
the box but there's an IndieGoGo
campaign going on for this case and it
is a minimalist case it is called the
Mod three radius X case it's not really
a case it's more kind of like a little
skeleton shell type thing because it's
not out yet this is a pre-production
release so they sent me this a tryout on
my phone I had one of these a long time
ago I don't remember which iPhone it was
but I loved it so much it just looks so
good you also have to screw it into
place so it's not something that you can
just take off easily it's gonna be quite
the process wish me luck and hopefully
it works out well since this is sort of
a pre-release version it may not fit
perfectly as the final one but I think
that we're gonna be okay
so let's open it up oh that was a lot
easier than I thought I think I was
making it more difficult okay so here's
our directions it's probably gonna be
pretty simple whoa this is it this is
gonna look so great on my phone I cannot
wait oh my goodness okay let's check our
directions here we've got a teeny tiny
little screws this looks fairly simple
so we remove this piece first I'm
shaking because I had so much coffee so
if you're wondering if I'm okay I think
so
this on top of here
I dropped the screw do you know how
small it is I was concerned that this
could potentially be a piece of dust
this is so small it is stuck underneath
my fingernail okay let's get this
together so I probably was supposed to
put this on first
it looks like it's fitting perfectly so
we screw this back into place and that's
it I thought it was gonna be a little
bit more difficult but that was
incredibly simple and oh my gosh it
looks beautiful I'm so happy right now
T - how many days until I shattered my
iPhone because I have not shattered it
yet and I'm super proud of that so I'm
hoping that it doesn't happen but
I am so reckless
[Music]
I am so excited I I think I'm actually
speechless I just wanted to show you
guys this because I thought it was
really great and I thought that a lot of
you guys may be into it as well let me
know what you guys think in the comments
below and are there any other similar
iPhone cases like this that you'd like
to see me test out and if anyone out
there is making pool iPhone cases please
let me know because so much fun to be
able to test them out and show you guys
some of the cool things that are out
there
cuz there's so much stuff that it is
completely overwhelming when you're
looking for a case this I still don't
think it's a case I cannot say this is
an iPhone case this is like a an art
piece it is a piece of jewelry kind of
like that crazy $1,400 case that I had
or 1200 whatever it's super expensive
but it was a piece of jewelry for your
phone and yeah I mean this looks good
you can't even tell me that this doesn't
look great because this looks amazing I
will see you guys in my next video thank
you so much for watching sorry this was
so short I thought that this was gonna
be a more complex thing and I'd probably
run into more issues but surprise no
issues and it fits perfectly
how long before I shatter my phone
that's what I'd like to know I think
it's okay but I oh man so I had just
shot the video I'm talking about this
new iPhone case and I was like oh I
wonder how long it was fine so I just
shot the video talking about this new
iPhone case well I didn't shatter it but
I did drop it it hasn't even been two
hours
[Music]